come on that's seven in a row it's
amazing you are Like This Woman's a
shark you are good at this game not
really just witness day
practical game of reading your opponent
and adjusting accordingly wait shoot
wait are you saying that you're reading
me
thank you
yes I can read you it's part of my
training everyone gives subtle hints
hints like what giveaways you boarded
the plane wearing a suit but no wedding
ring serious but not committed
you let a stranger sleep on your
shoulder kindness it also feels good to
be needed
the heart-shaped candy
either you have a problem with sugar
which based on the amount of maple syrup
you put on your pancakes this morning I
wouldn't think so or you have a problem
with candy in the shape of a heart which
means you might have a problem with
Romance
and things pertaining to this day in
particular
um
not bad Soldier
set
um
I'm Greg gilkins at my old High School
Henderson High and today's subject young
love I'm joined by Felicia whose
boyfriend Willie is still at track
practice but he'll be joining us shortly
so Felicia if he's the star athlete you
are not the cheerleader I'm on the dance
team maybe you could show us a little
bit
five six seven eight
don't hurt yourself
yeah wow I haven't seen moves like that
since the 94 Northridge Quake you guys
are
oh
so how do you two feel about each other
this Valentine's Day oh my gosh I
totally love him and I'm crazy about her
so Willy what is it about her that makes
you so happy oh she's beautiful she
makes me laugh and she does my geometry
bonus and Felicia what is it about
Willie that that's so cool oh well
besides the fact that he's totally hot
he's an amazing athlete come show him
babe
so good
whoa
so how did you guys meet it's really
funny actually like I was not into him
at first he used to shoot spit wads at
me in Spanish class which is like so
Junior High
but then one night I was brushing out my
hair when I got home and I found the
spit wad but it was really a note and it
said what's up and I was like that is so
cute and then I liked it
oh my God baby are you okay walk it off
baby just walk it off
you're still hot baby you're still hot
wow you rolled out of that like a ninja
he's usually really good at those yeah
well he's quite the athlete and you're
quite the dancer huh five six seven
eight I think we're I think we're okay
we I don't oh we haven't seen that one
to go she tell you the spit watch story
yes she did yeah she's mushy like that
so you like it
oh I miss high school
there you have it Young Love full of
Promise full of Hope ignorant of reality
from Henderson High on Valentine's Day
I'm Greg gilkins Channel 13. Happy
Valentine's Day Happy Valentine's to you
you look beautiful thank you
thank you Olivia's gonna need braces oh
that makes sense I had them you have
them I know
Bistro Gardens restaurant
good evening
hi Allison
excuse me
you're right okay sir
great well my name is Julia and I'm
going to be your server tonight
why don't I get started with a few
specials yes please tonight the chef is
featuring a dish that he likes to call
the lime stinking Pig
he starts by cutting off the pig's
testicles and he chops them up really
finely teeny tiny pieces and then he
takes those testicles and he he
pulverizes them and adds in a little
arugula some Sage um feta cheese and
shoves the mixture back up the pigs
well for lack of a better word ass
really
yeah then he cuts out the heart the cold
useless tiny little heart then uh
fillets it on either side and it's a
nice bush
of the sermon good choice
for you sir
I'm I'm not I I don't know just so you
know the um
heart of the pig
a little something like this
did we get a toy
maybe I'll give you a little time to
juggle the choices
[Music]
I love you
hey get out of the way
down in front Edgar where are you I know
you're out there who the hell is Edgar
he is my husband and shut your mouth
Edgar answer me answer her Edgar
where are you
still
Edgar answer me
that must be Edgar I'm here
I'm coming
oh sorry
I said hey run lower
listen to me I know I let you down and
maybe you don't think I deserve your
forgiveness but you're going to give it
to me anyway you're because when you
love someone you love all of them that's
the job I know that now
so sorry and now please you gotta love
everything about them not just the good
things but the bad things too the things
that you find lovable and the things
that you don't find logo on I understand
I'll never leave you
[Music]
[Applause]